today we are welcoming back to the
program congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district
located in the heart of silicon valley
congressman always great to have you on
great to be on so let's just start with
the covid relief bill
um popular with 76 percent of americans
even 60 of republicans rarely do you see
such agreement among uh 330 million
americans on anything
1.9 trillion dollars many people
wondering
what what are we waiting on right now
exactly
well we're going to pass it this week in
the house and then it goes to the senate
so we're waiting
as often on the senate and most of the
bill is going to go through the big
debate as you know
is whether the minimum wage will be uh
part of it the increase to 15
is uh at this point do you think
that understanding how popular the bill
is nationally
that republicans in the senate are
really going to stand in the way
or will some of them take the more
pragmatic approach of realizing that
this is popular even with many of their
constituents and it makes sense to
to be on the right side so to speak you
would think that but that's not the
indication i mean when you have mitt
romney coming out saying that
uh this is too big a bill and uh too
much spending i mean if he's not going
to be for it doesn't give me much hope
that
you're going to get many uh republicans
for it so i expect unfortunately that
this will be a straight party-line vote
how soon would the stimulus deposits
and or checks start getting to people if
it was passed
sometime next week it would be a few
weeks typically i mean i know
in the previous administration it
dragged on for
months and we still have some people who
are asking about
the 600 check from last time so i
hope we've learned from that typically
it takes about two to three weeks for
people to see the check after the
president signs it
in your mind would this be the last
coveted stimulus
i hope not i have called with tim ryan
since the
comic crisis began for monthly checks
because people's rent comes due every
month there are
a lot of folks who aren't getting
unemployment benefits i think we have to
continue until
uh the uh crisis is over until our
economy is fully open again and i'm
going to continue to push for that
what metrics would you look at to the
determine
when that is i guess i would look at the
unemployment rate
but not just the unemployment rate but
people who have opted out of the
workforce i would look at the infection
rate and the prevalence and seeing
uh how much uh we've been able to open
up our
economy again the 15 minimum wage
which is part of the version that is
currently
in in your chamber in the house of
representatives if that doesn't
ultimately get included in the bill is
that the next thing you'd like to see
congress take up or is there something
else
i would because it's the one thing that
represents structural change so the bill
is very important it gets money to
stay in local governments it gives money
for vaccines it gets money
uh of cash for every individual but it's
not structurally changing the economy
the minimum wage does it would
fundamentally increase wages for people
the challenges and bernie sanders made
this point yesterday that
you can't do the minimum wage without uh
reconciliation they're just not 60 votes
so yeah
you either have to get rid of the
filibuster or you have to do
reconciliation
which is why it's so important to get
this in uh the current bill
um when we talk about uh the immigration
situation
we covered on the program earlier this
week how
joe biden did very quickly do this
executive order
to stop the removals of um
undocumented immigrants back to a number
of different countries
but a judge very quickly kibboshed that
and since correct me if i'm wrong joe
biden has not attempted
with a different legal justification to
do another
executive order and i've read a number
of interesting legal assessments that
say if joe biden was really determined
to do this
there are a number of other ways that he
could word and structure executive
orders
the it was a it was very um
narrowly stopped by this texas judge and
joe biden hasn't done that
i've said that i think that if indeed
this is the priority joe biden said it
would be and that i believe it should be
he should be going right back at this
with another executive order and another
what do you think i agree with you i
mean i think that uh
we shouldn't let one judge stop the
process of having a more humane
uh immigration policy and the biggest
concern to me are
the kids and i'm sure you read also on
the on the detention
uh and and sending them there now there
are
alternatives you can have community
detention you can a community
placement uh and uh it's a question of
having the resources and the plan
so i think that this has to be looked at
i've looked
i'm on pramila jaipal's roadmap for
immigration she's going to be putting
out a plan
on how we keep our borders safe but are
not
treating most of the migrants coming
over particularly kids is criminals
so if job if joe biden doesn't do it if
he just leaves it as i did an executive
order and a judge stopped it and i guess
now we have to wait
would you consider that a failure
i don't think that's true to what he ran
on i mean we
every democratic candidate running said
that we were going to
look at the inhumane uh trump policy and
and return to a policy
uh of not criminalizing most people
crossing the border that
it is a civil infraction it you can be
uh sent back but uh there has to be a
move
that uh we aren't treating uh mothers
and kids as criminals and that we're
placing them in
uh in community placements instead of
these detention centers
in terms of the makeup of the house of
representatives
right now when we look at national
polling among republican voters
for the most part the support of the
former president
trump is is still significant um
something like 80
of republicans want him to remain
involved 64 percent
said if he split off and started his own
party
that they would follow him now i expect
that in practice
those numbers would be lower i i think
the idea of splitting off is more
appealing than
right actually doing it but needless to
say for the time being there there's
continued support among the republican
party for the former president
what is your assessment right now of the
impact within
your legislative body of the presence of
folks like
marjorie taylor greene and lauren
beaubert and madison cawthorn who
arguably are only even there
by riding on the coattails of trumpism
in the last six months of 2020.
well they've been marginalized uh from
the body but the challenge is that there
were almost 140 uh republicans who voted
for
the uh the opposing the certification of
the election
yeah and that's a lot of that's not just
some of these extreme cases
and so the decision the republican party
has to make and it's a very difficult
decision
is how do they move beyond trump without
abdicating
their base and i don't think any
republican actually has
figured that out i mean you have nikki
haley taking a different side of the
equation every day because they're
trying that balancing act but
uh and they've seen the consequences of
a liz cheney or someone who
tries a clean break and uh until they
are able to get
a coherent vision of a post-trump future
they're going to struggle is it naive to
think that this
fracturing particularly if this divide
becomes more noticeable
if donald trump does start his own party
or if he announces at cpac on sunday
that he's running as a republican in
2024
any of these things that might fracture
these two sides is it naive for me to
think that
it's an opportunity for the left to get
things done while they are fighting
amongst themselves
well i i think for the sake of the
country it would be better to have a
a coherent uh party that rejects uh uh
racism and that uh moves beyond trump uh
but what i would say is we have all the
tools we need but
we don't even have to focus right now on
the republicans what we have to do is
focus on how
controlling the house controlling the
senate the presidency we get our
things through and we ought to be doing
uh aggressively through reconciliation
the 15 wage that covered relief
infrastructure
uh and expanding health care so uh i
think we have an opportunity to
deliver on our agenda on health care
what do you see as as the next step
not in a perfect world where we might be
talking about medicare for all or
something else but
based on what joe biden ran on is it is
it
a simple let's establish a public option
what is it that you see as the immediate
next step on health care
well we should expand medicare and he
ran on expanding it to 60. that seems to
me an easy
yeah left we should look at how we at
least get
a public uh option uh that is uh
affordable
uh as a step towards a single player i
mean i believe fundamentally
medicare for all is the right solution
right but if they're what i would say is
let's look at any step in the lens of is
it getting us closer to that
uh ultimate goal and if and we should
support those parts that are
helping us move to in that direction in
your mind does this have to be done
before
2022 because we simply don't know who
will control what after that point
i do i mean i think it has to be done
not for the
sake of politics where people say oh if
you don't do this you'll lose the house
i just think
it's so rare in american politics if you
have the presidency the senate and the
house
and if we don't do this uh who knows
when all those stores align again
we're working very very hard to make
sure we keep the house i know senator
schumer's working hard to keep the
senate
and i think we have a very good chance
but uh politics is unpredictable and
while we have this opportunity
let's deliver on some structural change
to improve people's lives
in terms of the day-to-day in the house
you know we've had these stories
about metal detectors and we've learned
about
um congressman kawthorne saying that uh
with with his wheelchair he's able to
actually have multiple firearms with him
uh
and it's not obvious to others that
that's what's going on
are you feeling uh worried day-to-day
about firearms at the capitol
i personally am not but i feel i worry
for colleagues i worry for some of the
women of color
who've been uh subject to many death
threats i've i worry for people who have
uh been outspoken and targets on
uh on right-wing media uh and then i'm
sad for our country that every time i go
to the capitol it's basically a fortress
you have barbed wire you have
uh the national guard i mean it's a sad
thing that
we've created that distance between
government and people
uh because of the threats that uh are
there on the building
so you're not necessarily changing your
protocol
but much has changed at the capitol yeah
i mean everyone
is more vigilant that's just uh common
sense and
me and our team are more vigilant we
probably lock the doors more we're more
careful
we're making sure that we're not taking
unnecessary risks but
personally i don't feel uh threatened in
the way that some of my colleagues
unfortunately have been threatened
yeah uh you mentioned infrastructure
and this is such a big topic now
particularly in light of what happened
in texas
last week and of course we've gone into
detail about the way the texas grid
works the reality of
it's very plausible to winterize wind
turbines wind turbines are not the cause
of this issue
but can you talk a little bit about what
would
a green infrastructure deal look like
what would be the most important things
to include
in terms of the types of subsidies maybe
that would be put in place
the the types of jobs that we should be
looking to create how we should be
managing the reality that for the most
part we still do get most of our energy
from fossil fuels at this point in time
well david i chair the subcommittee on
the environment and we're going to be
holding a hearing on what happened in
uh texas and you're absolutely right but
one of the questions we're going to ask
with urcat is it's actually cheaper to
weatherize
uh wind turbines than it is to
weatherize
natural gas pipelines so shouldn't this
incident
have us move towards uh renewable energy
that's either easier to weatherize
that's easier to build infrastructure
around
we need to be built making that kind of
investment in renewable energy
generation
in battery storage in electric vehicle
and all of these things are going to
create jobs and we ought to have the
federal government help finance it or
take equity in it
because these are large capital projects
uh in
building the modern infrastructure for
the new energy economy
that is something that's jobs good jobs
and it's also something that's going to
help us tackle climate change
what will it ultimately take though to
to really signal a sea change in terms
of i mean your your state of california
has taken a pretty definitive position
on a new
new vehicle sales will have to be
electric after correct me if i'm wrong
is it 2035
yes some european countries germany for
example has taken
a similar approach but at the national
level rather than at the state level do
you think
ultimately the federal government is
going to have to
make some of those decisions in order to
really move forward
i do i think we ought to set those
centers i think those standards will be
good for american business it's good for
us
to lead in electric vehicles rather than
allowing china to lead
and we could create the incentive to
build those plants in places that have
lost
a manufacturing for example lordstown
lordstown ohio lost
an auto plant because we have a demand
for suvs over
uh over sedans well why don't we
incentivize that lordstown
lordstown ohio could become an electric
vehicle uh plant manufacturer or a
battery manufacturer one of the things
that's interesting is a lot of the
component parts
of electric vehicles could be made in
the united states
so we have to have a real view of how we
reindustrialize america
and if we do that it can be towards
climate change tackling it but also
towards job creation yeah there's a bit
of a myopic view
on on electric cars i mean certainly
right now tesla
is the lion's share of the market and
those are american vehicles
it's unbelievable what what's going on
but when you look at rivian you
look at pole star you you look at what
clearly is a growing presence
of chinese electric vehicles there's a
particular window of opportunity right
now that it sounds like you're saying
should should be seized before this goes
elsewhere
exactly and china currently leads in the
electric vehicle market i mean they
don't leave in the u.s market but they
lead in the
china market and the worldwide market
and a lot of the electric vehicle
manufacturers does by tesla are there
so we don't want china to eventually be
exporting to europe and to
be exporting to uh the rest of the world
we want uh our
countries to do companies to do that and
that's why it has to be collaborative
with the
government and the private sector to
innovate last thing i want to
ask about two structural issues that we
talk about so much in terms of how
future elections will will work
uh those are campaign finance how our
elections are financed and paid for
and also how how we count votes right
the idea of
first past the post within an electoral
college system
do you see the possibility of any
reform or changes on either of those two
issues in the next two years is there
even an
appetite for it right now within the
biden administration and the democratic
party
well hr one is all about this and it's a
big idea is to give uh individuals
matching funds to be able to contribute
yeah to eliminate big big money uh to
help have redistricting reform
i think it'll pass the house again the
question becomes what happens in the
senate
yeah and then the question becomes what
parts will the roberts court hold
uh constitutional my view is the big the
simplest thing is to
make every voter a donor give every
person a 50 credit to be able to use
uh on campaigns to democratize uh
finance
and lessen the value of big money yeah
well i mean
one interesting piece i read said that
that's a great half measure but ideally
you would eliminate
all of that and simply have straight
public financing of elections
do you see that democratization of funds
as an intermediate step or is the end
goal
i see it as an intermediate stuff i mean
i would love public financing of
elections but that just would be struck
down as unconstitutional under
uh the way this court has held blackley
vallejo and understanding of money a
speech so the voucher proposal
that larry lessig and some others have
come up with is to say that it's
constitutional even under a roberts
court
and if we can't uh get rid of the
billionaires spending money
at least we can dwarf them with citizen
resources and so that's the idea but
obviously it is a half
measure absolutely last thing we just
learned about joe biden's plan
to essentially pack the postal service
board of governors
adding three individuals so that then
louis de joy could be removed
does that sound to you like it will
happen as smoothly and as quickly as
summer are hoping
it should i hope so i applaud the
president for doing that i mean
lewiston joy was just a disaster not
just because of his trying to
play games with the election but his
view that you would basically privatize
the post service and that that was never
the intention when
private companies can explain to me how
they're going to guarantee
uh mail going across country for 50
cents and
the speed it does that we could talk but
the reality is they can't and there's a
reason that we have
a postal service that is a public entity
and we shouldn't be privatizing the few
public entities that are working in this
country
absolutely let's let's hope it does
happen that quickly and smoothly
uh congressman ro khanna of course from
california 17th district always great uh
catching up with you
thank you david thanks for having me as
always